مدمرات امريكا وبريطانيا تعلنان صد هجمات
جويه من اليمن فيما الشركات العالميه تعلق
رحلاتها في البحر الاحمر سلطنه عمان تدخل
على خط ازمه باب المندب النيران الصديقه
تصيب اسرى تل ابيب في القطاع والجيش
العبري يعترف هجوم مجهول يخترق الاجواء
المصريه الامريكان يكشفون امتلاك بايدن
لادوات ضغط على تلبيب هل يستخدمها اقتراح
امريكي لشعب القطاع لما بعد الح رب واشنطن
تحذر اي هجوم نووي لكوريا الشماليه سيؤدي
الى نهايه نظامكم اليابان تفرض حزمه
عقوبات ضد روسيا صحف امريكيه زياره
زيلينسكي الى واشنطن ادت الى تفاقم الوضع
في
كيف العوده للطاوله مع ازدياد الخسائر في
حرب القطاع تتجه الاطراف الى التوقف
والتفاوض وان الاذاعه العبريه تعلن ان تل
ابيب تدرس التوجه نحو صفقه تبادل اسرى بعد
حادثه مقتل ثلاثه محتجزين في الشجاعيه
اليكم
[موسيقى]
المصدر وكانت النيران الصديقه للعبري قد
اصابت جنودها حين اعترف الجيش العبري انه
قتل عن طريق الخط ثلاثه اسرى عبريين في حي
الشجاعيه شرق القطاع وها هو المصدر يتحدث
قر الجيش الاسرائيلي بان قواته قتلت ثلاثه
اسر عن طريق الخطا خلال معارك بحي
الشجاعيه شمال قطاع غزه ليعم الغضب في تل
ابيب بخروج مسيره غاضبه خرجت امام وزاره
الدفاع تطالب بصفقه فوريه لاستعاده باقي
المختطفين في القطاع فيما ادت وسائل اعلام
عبريه بمقتل اسيره اخرى في القطاع ليخرج
مث تم الفصائل ناطقها قائلا ان الجيش
العبري لازال يقامر بحياه جنوده الاسرى
غير ابه بمشاعر عائلاتهم وقد تعمد اعدام
ثلاثه منهم واثر قتلهم على تحريرهم قبل
ذلك ذكر موقع اكسيوس الامريكي ان اجتماعا
مرتقبا سيجمع مدير الموساد ديفيد بارنيا
ورئيس الوزراء القطري محمد بن عبد الرحمن
ال ثاني في اوروبا نهايه هذا الاسبوع
لاستئناف مفاوضات الرهائن فيما قالت صحيفه
جيروسالم بوست ان مجلس الوزراء الع بر كان
قد صادق على دخول مساعدات انسانيه الى
القطاع عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم بين القطاع
وتل ابيب دوليا اعلنت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه ان مدمره صواريخ امريكيه موجهه
اسقطت 14 طائره مسيره اطلقها الحوثيون فوق
البحر الاحمر واعلنت بريطانيا ان احدى
مدمرات اسقطت ما يعتقد بانها مسيره هجوميه
كانت تستهدف الملاحه في البحر الاحمر من
جانب اخر قال المتحدث باسم الحوثيين محمد
عبد السلام انهم يجرون محادثات بواسطه
سلطنه عمان مع اطراف دوليه بشان العمليات
المستمره في البحر الاحمر وبحر العرب واكد
عبد السلام ان الحوثيين سيواصلون استهداف
السفن العبريه والسفن المتجهه الى تلبيب
حتى وقف الهجوم ورفع الحصار عن القطاع
فيما نفذ سلاح الجو التابع للقوات المسلحه
اليمنيه عمليه عسكريه على اهداف حساسه في
منطقه ايلات العبريه بدفعه كبيره من
الطائرات المسيره هناك اعلنت شركه ميرس
العالميه للشحن البحري تعليق رحلاتها
المتجهه الى المدخل الجنوبي للبحر الاحمر
عقب هجوم على احدى سفنها في وقت اعلنت فيه
شركه هابج لويد الالمانيه انها تدرس
التوقف مؤقتا عن الابحار في البحر الاحمر
اليكم المصدر اعلنت شركه ميرسك الدنماركيه
للنقل البحري تعليق مرور سفنها عبر مضيق
باب المندب في مصر افاد موقع القاهره
الاخباريه نقلا عن مصادر بان الدفاعات
الجويه المصريه رصدت جسما طائرا وتعاملت
معه بشكل فوري قباله سواحل مدينه ذهب
بينما ذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يمتلك ادوات ضغط على
تلبيب لحثها على تبني نهج جديد في الحرب
لتجنب قصف المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه
واوضحت الصحيفه ان من بين تلك الوسائل
لاستخدام نفوذ المساعدات الماليه العسكريه
السنويه لتل ابيب التي اقرت في حقبه
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما هنا
قال المتحدث باسم الجيش العبري جوناثان
كونريكوس ان استعاده الرهائن عسكريا تحد
هائل ومهمه صعبه للغايه كما تحدث عن صعوبه
المعركه قائلا انه يتعين على العبريين دفع
ثمن من الدماء من اجل تحقيق اهدافهم وان
الامر لن يكون سهلا فيما قالت صحيفه وول
ستريت جورنال ان مستشار الامن القومي جيك
سوليفان اقترح على السلطه الفلسطينيه
تدريب قوات امن لضبط الاوضاع الامنيه ما
بعد حرب القطاع في الحدود اللبنانيه اعلنت
مقاومه لبنان شن خمس هجمات ضد اهداف عبريه
ليرد الجيش العبري انه رصد ثلاث عمليات
اطلاق نار من لبنان وانه رد بقصف مدفعي
باتجاه عدد من الاهداف داخل الاراضي
اللبنانيه بعيدا عن حرب القطاع حذرت
واشنطن كوريا الشماليه من ان اي هجوم نووي
تشنه عليها او على حلفائها غير مقبول
وسيؤدي الى نهايه نظام كيم جونج اون حسب
ما جاء في بيان مشترك للولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه واكد الجانب الامريكي
مجددا ان اي هجوم نووي تشنه بيونج يانج
على سيول سيقبل برد سريع وساحق
وحاسم عوده
مخيبه عاد بخفي حنين هكذا يقولها العرب
ونقلت مجله فورين بوليسي بان زياره الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ادت الى تفاقم الوضع في
كيف واضافت المجله طلب البيت الابيض من زل
نسكي وقف المكالمات مع الكابيتول ال
بالاضافه الى ذلك منعت اداره بايدن محاوله
اخرى من قبل قاده الكونجرس لاقامه اتصالات
منتظمه مع كبار المسؤولين الاوكرانيين في
كيف من جانبه صرح الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ان روسيا تواصل تطوير البنيه
التحتيه وتعمل على تطوير قوات الردع
الاستراتيجي ليخرج الصحفي البريطاني ماثيو
بارس ويقول انه من غير الممكن ان يستمر
الصراع في اوكرانيا الى غير مسمى لذلك يجب
على الغرب دعم محادثات السلام التي ستؤدي
الى تنازلات اقليميه من كيف مشيرا الى ان
اي قياده في كيف يجب ان تكون قادره على
اخبار الاوكرانيين بانها ابرمت صفقه تجلب
السلام الدائمه والازدهار والامن وان كان
ذلك داخل الحدود التي اجبرت على التكيف
معها مما صغر بلادهم الى حد ما في اليابان
افادت وزاره الاقتصاد والتجاره والصناعه
بان الحكومه فرضت حزمه جديده ده من
العقوبات ضد روسيا بما في ذلك قيود
التصدير على 57 شركه بالعوده الى الميدان
الاوكراني قال مصدر امني ان سته من حرس
الحدود الاوكراني استسلموا للجيش الروسي
على اتجاه كورسك بحسب وكاله نوفوستي بينما
اعلن الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط 30 طائره
مسيره روسيه استهدفت عده مناطق في كيف في
المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
الطيران العملياتي التكتيكي والطيران
العسكري والمسيرات والصواريخ والمدفعيه
الروسيه قصفت افرادا ومعدات عسكريه تابعه
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه في
125 منطقه كما انها اسقطت مروحيه اوكرانيه
من طراز مي ايت واضافت الوزاره الروسيه ان
منظومات الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اسقطت ست
مسيرات اوكرانيه اخرى اطلقت قوات كيب فوق
شبه جزيره القرم الروسيه يصل بذلك اجمالي
الطائرات الاوكرانيه المسيره التي اسقطها
الدفاع الجوي الروسي الى 32 مسيره خلال 24
ساعه